[Music]
heartbreakingly tender
heartwarmingly timeless
christopher plummer's role is captain
von trapp in the sound of music not only
made him a star
it made him a legend i'm very grateful
to the sound of music
in making me well known
for start and able to choose projects
rather than ask for them but he was
never fond of the sound of music which
he often referred to as
that movie christopher described the
musical as being sentimental
and gooey but he always seemed content
on stage begin his career in the 1950s
christopher acted on broadway
and with ontario's famed stage company
the stratford festival both of which
he would often return to throughout his
career the first time you saw your name
up in lights
it wasn't big enough
christopher made his big screen debut in
1958's
stage struck you want me to write you an
exit speech well it's much too early in
the morning for that
while he would go on to build an
illustrious film career it wasn't until
his 2010 role as a gay father
beginners that he won an academy award
if andy wasn't going to be monogamous
why should i be
winning at age 82 christopher was the
oldest oscar winner
in history it's a sort of general
acceptance of your work so
it is it's thrilling more recently
christopher was nominated for a golden
globe and an academy award for his work
in
all the money in the world a surprising
nod considering he was a last-minute
replacement for scandal play kevin
spacey
i said yes thank you very much i'll take
the risk
always candid christopher admitted in
his 2008 memoir in spite of myself
that he was wildly promiscuous in his
younger days
yes you have to be the bad guy to be
interesting that's what we all thought
but it all changed when christopher
married his third wife
elaine in 1970. we're never in each
other's hair
occasionally we have a you know
knock down fight but it's usually so
theatrical that we break up laughing and
say oh my god oh that was over the top
but christopher's connection with his
only child amanda was a little more
complicated
admitting that he was an absentee father
in his daughter's formative years
christopher eventually built a bond with
amanda later in life when i got to know
her it wasn't
an obsessive parent it was just a new a
new friend
and so we treated ourselves like friends
which is actually
terrific as for his relationship with
acting
you could say it was a lifelong bond
we don't retire in our business we
either die
on the stage or in front of a camera i
hope i'm
properly made up the time look as young
and
and rosario-like as i won't want to be
you